so how was the Marathon Man speaking of
food it was uh it was the hardest thing
I've ever done were you in so much pain
the next day that like even if you
wanted to consume all the calories you
lost like you just couldn't yeah my
mouth is really weird it was like where
my mouth where like the roof of my mouth
meets my throat that part
yep keep going like if you were to like
jam something in right I'm kidding it
was like because I have a I have like
ticks like nervous habits that I do and
one of them is
and I think I was in so much pain
the whole race I was just doing that
over and over again for nine hours wow
so that part of my like roof of my mouth
was super like raw which is weird and so
I couldn't eat afterwards like yesterday
I was trying to eat but it just hurt
please no jokes about my throat being
raw
it's gonna be all jokes that race
grabbed you by the back of the head
give me some Cody okay it did man it was
it was so hard what was your time my
time was 9 hours and 45 minutes which
actually I'm really proud of because I
didn't think I'd be able to break 10
hours I actually didn't really have any
perspective on like what a good time was
you know in the middle of it what where
does that rank I got 16th overall I
think like I don't know 100 or something
like that
so like I definitely like performed well
but it's hard to say because like you
start and everyone just kind of
dissipates right away like within the
first 10 miles everyone's just by
themselves so you're kind of like I
don't know like people pass you once
every like hour someone will just like
approach from nowhere and you're like oh
what the f and they'll buy and you're
like where did they how did
nothing makes sense did you have no
perspective on like where you are how
you're performing and by the middle of
it like four hours in or something I was
like I think I got that I felt pretty
good and I was like I think I could
probably break 10 hours the whole like
I gotta ask you the part I really care
about yeah did you pass anybody did I
pass anyone let's hear these overtakes
how'd you set them up so I had this one
guy right are you being serious no
I don't think I passed a single person
then what well I mean like there were
times where but it wasn't like racing
where it's like okay
no but you didn't see a guy like in the
distance get him on the no but you
didn't see the guy in the distance
you're like oh my God
it's like you see a guy in the distance
like going up a hill I just want to
survive this next five steps yeah
exactly yeah you're not even sure if
like you see a real Rush yeah exactly
it's cross-eyed like
hey just you screaming at a tree damn
16th though yeah we within the first
like 10 miles I was running with my
brother-in-law uh we passed this girl
who stepped on a rock weird and snapped
her ankle
and some guys that she was with were
like helping her they were like kind of
trying to pick her up and she's like
[ __ ] it I'll just crawl and we were like
oh my God this is like a hiking trail
right it's like rocks and sticks and
she's three miles from anything in
either direction from any help
and a helicopter had to come pick her up
and like save her later whoa I don't
know how that [ __ ] doesn't happen more
because it's just the whole like half
the
shittiness of this is just avoiding
rocks and brutal downhills where the
whole time you're just like rolling your
ankle so describe this terrain to us
does it start on street and then you're
immediately into a forest or is there
like a significant period where you're
kind of on flat ground or now it's
basically just like a trail like this
okay it's just in the forest or you're
on the mountain got it and it's just up
and down up and down up and down 23
miles in I think there was like a three
mile stretch that was just flat and it
was just Stray From Heaven that's how
you know that [ __ ] was horrible that
flat ground in the middle of a forest
you were like thank God I know right
sorry continue no that's true like
normally it's just like I don't want to
run even the flats are like this is
[ __ ] annoying it's running but I was
like anything anything other than a
downhill or an uphill and you don't even
know like which one's worse yeah like
when you're on a brutal uphill it's like
I wanna I wanna [ __ ] all I want right
now is down a down and then you're on
the down and you're like I just
it it sucks more yeah the downhills yeah
like I was just getting pissed I was
like pissed at the trail like I was
feeling really good for the first 10
miles and they had this brutal downhill
and I get to the first aid station or
the second aid station and my mom's
there and she's like how's it going and
I was like
I was having so much fun in this [ __ ]
downhill I was just pissed
Canadian dude yeah
I'm not happy
I'll say that much
okay do you want to like yeah I hate you
want to swear anything no no no no no no
no no just uh
I think they could have did a better job
choosing that's it Frick yeah frick
frick yeah that's what it was I really
was there's no other way to describe it
but just I was mad at the path yeah yeah
I was gonna say did you finish the race
they're like hey you just turn around
you're like
[ __ ] you dude
Curry great job just uh here with the
local paper just curious uh what are
your thoughts top top 20 awesome what an
accomplishment how you feel right now
just I [ __ ] hate trees
okay and actually rocks can suck my dick
as well okay and dirt okay
I was so tired by the end like I had
this so like the the race was 60
kilometers that's like the you know
because it's metric system but my watch
was in miles so
and and the I had it like downloaded on
all Trails which was like a hiking app
and it told me it was 36.6 miles so
that's the number I was looking for for
the whole time nine hours I was just
like 36.6 that's what I have to get to
36.6 and I get to 38 36.5 and I'm like
count point one miles away from the
finish I should start hearing music or
something and it wasn't coming I was
like I bet you I bet you this thing's
wrong I bet you was longer sure enough
36.6 comes and goes I'm still not even
close I don't think I can't see anything
I don't have no indication of where the
Finish is
wait 60 is 37.2 oh yeah but this app
told me that's what it was yeah this is
like yeah it has like a map like it's
pretty exact so it must have been a
previous year and they like changed it
year by year so what did it end up being
it was so then I see this guy running
backwards like a volunteer or something
like that he was running the other way
to go do something and I was like how
dude how far is it and he was like oh
dude it's 500 meters you're almost there
it's everything it seems like it's
nothing but it's everything in that
moment where all you want to do is
finish so for the last 500 meters I
would run five steps and I literally had
nothing left because I was I was saving
everything for that last little bit yeah
I would run five steps
laughs
literally that's that's what I was doing
and this guy this is like 20 year old
Jack dude
passed me out of nowhere and goes finish
strong man I was like you [ __ ]
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] this Trail
genetic Phenom yeah go [ __ ] yourself
such a such a funny thing to say to
someone who's just standing in the
middle of the trail elbows on their
knees looking at the ground finish
strong man
are you even real yeah yeah he says I
said he just starts like running up into
the sky going to Valhalla yeah the guy
running the other way wasn't real either
yeah yeah nothing yeah you just imagined
the whole thing yeah how far am i dude
you're 500 liters all right for sure
foreign
you wake up you're in that helicopter
you broke your ankles you're gonna be
all right
you got 10 milligrams of dexedrine in
your brother you're gonna be A-Okay you
just look down your legs
Tetris piece
what happened I don't know man I think
the downhill got you you seem pretty
upset you tripped right at the beginning
you hadn't even started yet they shot
the gun and you got scared and fell over
yeah they shot the gun and you got
scared and you stumbled backwards back
into the porta potty and then you fell
with the Porta-Potty you fell into the
into the toilet yeah and then it then
the whole Porta-Potty like went over
with your weight and it tumbled about
200 feet that's why your mouth is
covered in [ __ ]